in terms of the the most important
scientific discovery to come out of my
group there was a acute moment or the
Eureka moment so to speak and and this
was in 1994 and by that time my
colleagues and I have been immersed in
AIDS research already and we realized
that for any given patient with HIV
infection his or her viral load or the
amount of virus and the blood tends to
remain rather constant over time and and
we've been thinking about that why does
it remain constant and gradually we
really realized that it was a what we
call dynamic equilibrium that is the
amount of the virus being made is
approximately equal to the amount of
virus being cleared so it was a steady
state and then the eureka moment came
when we had the opportunity to
administer new drugs to HIV infected
people and then within weeks of doing so
we collected the data and showed that
viral load actually dropped
precipitously and of course that is a
great outcome for the patient and for
the doctor but the question that we
posed was why does it drop and why does
it drop in that acute manner and and
this is where my quantitative background
in physics applied is that we we
realized that we could actually write
that out mathematically in a straight
forward differential equation that ap
high school student would be able to do
and from there you fitting the data and
doing the calculation we were able to
come up with the idea that that it was a
we were using the drugs to block virus
in
affection and production and therefore
the precipitous decline reflect the fact
that the virus was constantly being
clear at a very rapid rate and so using
that quantitative background we were
able to calculate what the turnover of
virus was all the time in a given
infected person and that number turned
out to be enormous ly large so the virus
was just replicating away at a rapid
clip and from there we also knew that
HIV eat changes every time it replicates
so high replication rate met high error
rate and therefore HIV was able to
mutate very quickly and we could then do
the additional calculation to show that
well if you treat this virus with one or
two drugs at a time the virus is
predictably going to mutate and escape
from the action of the drugs but at the
same time we could also calculate what
it would take to corner the virus so
it's not able to escape and those
calculations suggested to us that three
or more drugs would do the trick and so
we knew that by 1995 and and and
launched a series of experiments in
patients using what is now called a
cocktail therapy throughout three drugs
or more and immediately within weeks we
saw the good result but we wanted to
wait to see if the results could be
sustained and it was only by middle of
1996 we realized that we were able to
keep the virus below detection level for
a good year and that opened up the door
for for what is called combination
therapy today
I'm not sure there was one moment that
sparked my interest in math and sciences
I think as far as I could recall I have
always had some interests in these areas
I certainly remember being a very
curious child and perhaps that has that
is a precursor to pursuing science but I
think there's also quite a bit of family
influence that affected me gradually and
and that has to do with having a number
of important family members who pursue
science or engineering including my
father in a very important uncle and
they they're interested in technology
and in sciences I think had a great deal
of influence on my decision ultimately
to to pursue science
in terms of the mass education in Taiwan
it was quite intense and so the math
that I had learned by 6 grey served me
pretty well until about eighth or ninth
grade here in the US in terms of science
education we didn't have that much
formal science in Taiwan and I began to
be exposed to that in the later years in
middle school and of course in high
school and so I think I was first
grounded in math and then gradually
shifted into the sciences that's what I
remember
my career did not go as planned
initially as I said my interest was in
physics but through my college education
I saw the coming of new biology and and
and the promises of biomedical research
so I shifted my interest from physics to
to life sciences and and ultimately went
to medical school with the idea that I
would somehow pursue medical research
and my real focus in medicine did not
come until sometime later when I was
doing my clinical training and when I
first encountered patients with what we
now call AIDS and that sparked a real
interest in me and I have pursued that
kind of research ever since now 1982
I I was initially interested in
cardiology but gradually I realize
infections affect many many people
throughout the world and many of the
infections are actually manageable or
treatable and we could make an impact
and in particular I was interested in
new infections that plagued the world
and when I was doing my medical training
there were a number of new infections
that emerge including what we call
Legionnaires disease and Lyme disease
today but as I was finishing medical
training I encounter some of the
earliest cases of hiv/aids and I
realized that was a fascinating
scientific challenge in terms of trying
to understand what was the underlying
cause but I did not realize that he
would become a major public health
problem until sometime later
well I was doing my chief medical year
as chief resident in internal medicine
in the west side of Los Angeles when the
very first case was a young homosexual
man who presented to the hospital with a
multitude of problems all of which
suggests that his immune system was not
functioning very well and that was
curious to me because he was not getting
any chemotherapy or radiation or any
drugs that would suppress the immune
system it was immediately clear that we
were looking at something new because
such a case was never described in the
textbooks and and then he was treated
for his acute problems but only to die a
few weeks later and then another case
that was quite similar came in and
another and another in rapid succession
we had five such cases and it was too
much of a coincidence to observe this
and we realized that something was going
on with a common theme and from there
medical history it was pretty clear that
it was a transmissible disease and the
search was on to hunt down that that
microbe that was the underlying cause
you